over the last few years I saw a lot of
videos on YouTube that says good guys
comes last there are even a few big
youtubers that make videos on how to be
a bad guy
so first I just ignored it but recently
I got a few video requests to make a
video of how to be a cool bad guy so I
decided I just have to make a video that
is basically the opposite because I do
not believe that good guys comes last
there's no evidence that supports it as
well
so in this video I'm gonna talk about
good guys do not come last when it comes
to relationships and to life itself when
we look at the bigger picture so let's
get right into the video
now let's look at relationships first
there's a lot of people out there that
believe good guys comes last when it
comes to relationships but isn't that
true
definitely not studies has actually
shown that women that are looking for
the right guy prefer someone with a good
and kind heart especially when it comes
to long-term relationships now if you're
a good guy they know that they can trust
you and that you'll be a good father as
well and even though a girl might date a
bad guy or two at the end they usually
come to their senses and realize that
they don't want to settle for a bad guy
because a woman who is content with
herself in her life knows what she wants
and won't put up with a bad guy but
sadly it often takes a bad guy or two
for women to realize what she wants and
what she deserves how she deserves to be
treated so at the end bad guys actually
helps good guys to win because they help
women to appreciate good guys a lot more
now for most young and insecure women
out there the appeal of a bad guy might
be because she confuses his boldness and
bad guy style for confidence and most
girls one a strong confident guy that
they can rely on so it is a men's
confidence in himself that attracts a
lot of girls and some other woman might
just want a very quick date and a bad
guy is better for her today because he
thinks she won't get too emotionally
attached and if you're a good guy and
want a longer term relationship with a
good woman these are not the kind of
women that you want to date anyway it's
a woman do not dislike good guys that is
a wrong assumption what they dislike is
guys that come across as having very low
self-esteem
and looking desperate by being over
to such a degree that people walk all
over them or push them around so they
don't like pushovers girls like good
guys that are confident in themselves
it's kind of common sense because how
can a woman be confident in a man if
he's not even confident in himself I'm
not saying that it's not possible I'm
just saying it's a lot harder for women
to fall in love with or like a guy that
he's not confident in himself now I've
heard that there's a lot of women out
there that complain and they say hey
where has all the good men gone there's
so few good guys out there in the world
today and you've probably heard it
yourself as well the perception that
there's so few good guys out there is
actually a good thing for you if you're
a good guy because it increases your
value so much more so if you're a good
guy do not change now for any girl out
there lamenting over a bad guy what
you're probably really sad about is the
fantasies that you've been created in
your mind about this guy because it is
very easy to see a bad guy for what you
imagine him to be in the future as well
compared to what he really is
so my advice to you is be very careful
because you might experience a lot of
pain in the future if you're not careful
that being said I have seen a few really
good guys changed because of a good
woman but that is not guaranteed so do
you want to know what he's sexier than a
bad guy it's a good guy
that treats you with respect a gentleman
a good man does not love a million girls
he loves one girl in a million ways
because good men see the whole picture
they know that the real power of a man
lies in the size of the smile of the
woman sitting next to him don't just
judge a man on his looks or material
possessions there are a lot of good guys
out there in the world you'll find them
when you start to evaluate men based on
their character you'll find an honest
kind strong motivated a hard-working man
that treats you the way you should be
treated
now let's look at the bigger picture
here a lot of bad guys out there believe
that good guys comes last why because
they don't realize that good guys are
usually running a different race
some people make generalized assumptions
that good guys are pushovers so let me
make it clear
being a pushover and being a good guy
it's not the same thing a good man you
can see the whole picture of life he has
insight and wisdom so he knows when to
control his emotions while bad guys
they're more like tunnel they just see
tunnel vision and I try to act tough to
get what they want but you know it is
easy to get angry to be arrogant rude
and selfish in this world but it takes
more inner strength to be kind and to be
humble let me explain nice guys are
winners even before the race starts
because they have the ability to see the
bigger picture of the consequences of
their decisions and actions good men and
women are the only people that are
keeping this world from falling apart
pollution
crime
corruption are increasing everywhere
every day and people are finding it
harder and harder to cope of everything
that is going on did you know there's
3,000 suicides every day and 60,000
attempted suicides every day so the last
thing we need is more videos on YouTube
telling people to be bad guys so you
won't be a pushover because fighting
evil with evil is just gonna continue
this endless cycle you don't have to be
a bad guy to cope in a bad well think
about this 60,000 people in the world
are trying to kill themselves every day
because the world is already bad enough
a world where people are becoming more
selfish arrogant and having less empathy
for another human being we are all born
innocent but as we grow up and
experience the world and as we
experience pain then there's usually a
point in everybody's life where they
have to make a decision and how they are
gonna choose to live in this world am I
gonna become harder to kind of deal with
this world that is becoming darker every
day or will I stand my ground and stand
against it the easier choice will just
be to go along for favorite won't it
that's what most people do but will you
stand your ground fight against it to
make this world a better place will you
become a good man that this world so
desperately needs now I've told you that
being a good guy and a pushover is not
the same thing so what is a good guy and
what makes them different from bad guys
good men are bold yet humble strong yet
gentle they are confident not arrogant
kind but not weak
they are dependable trustworthy
forgiving self-controlled discreet
attentive loving and well-mannered
good man is a gentleman a good man can
be shamed because it shows his conscious
stole works good man can be embarrassed
because it shows that he's not
completely egocentric good man can blush
emotionally dye-sensitized now don't
ever mistake a good man's heart for
weakness because it takes a lot more
true strength and courage to be a good
man in this world bad guys will always
come last because their perception of
what it means to be a good guy is wrong
a bad guy can never be a true leader
only a good man can because the
character of a good man encourage other
people to become better men and build a
better world for everyone I personally
do not want to be an arrogant alpha male
that just cares about myself trying to
be better than other people looking down
on them and think that my value as a
human being is higher than other people
I would rather be a lone wolf that is
not influenced by guru pressure and that
stands his ground for what is right even
if it is against a pack of wolves
because with time this lone wolf will
inspire others and in so doing become a
good leader that will serve and build up
others to become good leaders as well
you have to make your choice to become a
good guy or a bad guy I made my choice
years ago when I lost my second brother
died in a car crash and it shocked my
whole life
but this bankfull experience allowed me
to see the bigger picture of life I
realized that life is only temporary my
life yours is like a flower one day
we're here the next will be gone and at
that moment I realized I was living my
life selfishly and I had no peace in my
heart so I made my choice I decided to
change to become better to become a good
guy and you have to make your own
decision
because when you die and you will
because everybody dies
you cannot take money or any other
material possessions with you but you
will leave behind the influence that you
had on other people so let me ask you
how do you want people to remember you
the choice is yours
you